happy new years everybody a while back
we did an episode called before they
were famous where he showed commercials
that famous people warned before they
blew up you guys really seemed to dig it
also you left us comments with ideas for
commercials that we didn't even know
about or totally missed out on so we're
doing another one we're giving you more
welcome to first off you know we're from
Saturday Night Live love-30 rock but
this bank commercial features a young
boyish Tina Fey from before she was
famous hi can have a lot of different
meanings for example hi nice to meet you
or hey I have no idea who you are
and then there's hi as in did you see
the current interest rate of mutual
savings bank it's really high Tina Fey
why are you in this abandoned building
after this shoot she was sadly bitten by
a stray dog and contracted rabies next
up we got Michael Scott himself
Steve Carell in an ad for an Illinois
chicken restaurant big news from brows
chicken we now have cholesterol free
better - so our chicken is cooked
completely cholesterol free and it
tastes just as great as always we
figured a lot of people would like our
new healthier way of cooking but quite
frankly the response has been better
than we'd anticipated Brown's chicken
isn't bad but I'm more of a placer monos
man myself
one celebrity who kept popping up in the
comments you left jesse pinkman aka
Aaron Paul 1-800 collect tombstone pizza
vanilla coke but the one that you guys
mentioned the most corn pops no not the
heart not now acting a little recurrent
pod yeah uh-huh
just leave a pamphlet on the table al
Rita after Brett off responsibility huh
man all I want to do is eat what is what
is said so do we have an understanding
uh-huh gotta have my pop is it just me
or was he really jonesing for those corn
pops he was like I'm a meth head
for corn pops nice work Aaron Paul
getting it to character early let me ask
you a question do you love Aaron Paul
and gum you're in luck
got a half sweet gotta have juicy fruit
nothing satisfies like it
okay they both had telekinesis where did
this commercial take place at Xavier
school for gifted youngsters in this
next one
check out Magic Mike himself Channing
Tatum in a mountain Dew commercial
what's up forgot my do
hey Channing Tatum you know what they
have everywhere 7-elevens and Mountain
Dew pull into a parking lot and buy one
like a normal person you jerk you
reckless maniac
check out Shaun of the Dead himself
Simon Pegg and what I think is a cough
syrup commercial but I don't speak
British
uh hi mister hello hello no I can't come
into words about I'm I'm in bed a cough
it's better the butter cut was brilliant
yeah I've got a ton of any good thing
they're really kind of it I've got a
headache but something inside I don't
see um somebody let the dog out I'm the
cab pickup is so effective at relieving
coughs and colds you'll have to think of
a better excuse what if I try this rebro
I'm okay but it's right contagious when
you're feeling dead and like you're at
World's End make that hot fuzz in your
throat go away with buttercups syrup hey
guys you know what Leonardo DiCaprio
loves more than banging supermodels
bubble yum check it out
this is a chunk of supersoft bubble
bubble gum this is a loud thumping -
pumping boom box both were known for
black
wrong the young as the fun that never
blows out big mouth busting bubble young
keeps a poppin
now rumor has it that Martin Scorsese
was watching Nickelodeon in the 90s I
think it might have been Clarissa
explains it all and then that Bubble Yum
commercial came on and he was like oh
I'm gonna cast this guy in all my movies
let me just tell you Marty he's not
exactly Robert De Niro before Stephen
Colbert was hosting his TV show The
Colbert Report he was doing a weird
commercial for a bank in Nebraska at
first year we have three words for
convenience your first here your first
here you're first here thought I was
gonna say location location location
right I could have
because we put you first at locations
all over Nebraska you're first here at
first here you're first here at first
tier some of the worst word plan ever
heard and finally here's a clip
featuring a young hunk who I think has a
very bright future
we have over 60 unique flavors that
Texans love I have an idea for a new
flavor what
aspirin flavor aspirin yeah so when
you're eating your ice cream really fast
and you get an ice cream headache boom
you already took some aspirin
oh I can watch that thing over and over
again and if you live in the state of
Texas you probably had to sorry that was
pretty fun now if you could see any
celebrity being a commercial for any
product what would it be
leave an answer in the comment section
below our favorite answer gonna get a
screen junkies t-shirt right now I want
to give a couple shoutouts first I want
to say hi to Kourtney Cheshire and thank
you for sending in this awesome picture
perfectly capturing a bye-bye moment
also I want to say what's up to my main
man Jordan reads who watches us outside
of Baltimore Maryland Jordan thanks for
watching the show and I want to thank
you for watching I'm how Rudnick hit me
up on Twitter bye bye I try to turn the
day was over he had a problem that's
Walter White in a skunk suit if you
smell that bad at the end of the day
that's not a soap issue that's a medical
issue